[Música]
para mí es un sueño excelente
le doy gracias a la vida por darme la
oportunidad de darme estos pequeños
minutos de explicarles un poco sobre mi
experiencia
con el compromiso de que en los
siguientes minutos les hablaré desde el
corazón
mi esposa me ha demostrado que es la
única forma a través de la cual puedes
dejar huella en las personas
precisamente por eso me gustaría iniciar
esta charla haciéndoles algunos
comentarios
y me gustaría preguntarles a ustedes
quién de ustedes cree que la
inteligencia marca el éxito en las
personas levanten la mano
[Música]
no muchas personas por otro lado me
gustaría que levantara la mano a
aquellas personas que crean que las
emociones influyen en el éxito de las
personas
y mucho más
algo que vale mucho la pena y que
realmente quiero mencionarles a todos
ustedes
es que el común denominador de las
personas llega a pensar que el éxito de
los grandes empresarios que existen en
todo el mundo se basa principalmente en
un golpe de suerte se basa en que heredó
algún tipo de negocio o simplemente
porque tuvo la oportunidad de tener
o de estudiar en una universidad de un
gran renombre
la mayoría de nosotros pensaría claro
por eso esa persona es exitosa
sin embargo nos damos cuenta que no
siempre esa es la clave del éxito
porque muchas veces aquellas personas
que tienen esas oportunidades de
estudiar en algunas universidades de
tener ciertos amigos o simplemente haber
heredado algo no necesariamente llevan
al éxito a sus negocios
muchas veces lo que sucede es que
les falta algo son personas racionales
pero no son personas emocionales
precisamente por eso lo que me gustaría
indicarles a ustedes
es que la inteligencia emocional es
sumamente importante para las compañías
actualmente las compañías están en la
búsqueda de mejorar como tal su
rendimiento mejorar como tal la
productividad y obviamente obtener
mayores beneficios económicos
a lo largo de esta carrera ha habido
inversiones que se realizan por parte de
las compañías mejorando los procesos
inversiones en tecnología sin embargo
llega un momento en el cual se dan
cuenta que las personas son las que
toman decisiones o las personas son
realmente los individuos que en su caso
marcan la pauta del éxito de una
compañía
eso ha traído consigo que entonces las
empresas estén prestando una mayor
atención en las cualidades habilidades y
conocimientos y en la forma en la cual
los individuos interactúan con otras
personas
el éxito de una empresa radica en la
importancia y en la toma de decisiones
de los individuos que colaboran en la
misma
veo muchos alumnos y quisiera darles un
buen comentario
al día de hoy muchas gracias
creo que llegó un poco tarde pero
al día de hoy las compañías como tal no
sólo prestan atención en la experiencia
profesional o comercial de los
individuos
prestan también atención en la forma en
la cual se interactúan los individuos
con otras personas porque esto traerá
consigo como tal una afinidad un trabajo
en equipo
precisamente por eso
la inteligencia emocional es sumamente
importante
a partir de este momento todavía no les
he explicado o comentado que es la
inteligencia emocional me gustaría
comentar que la inteligencia racional
como habitualmente nosotros la
consideramos es aquella capacidad
psicológica que nosotros tenemos o que
cada individuo tiene para realizar test
de inteligencia y que se ve reflejado
como tal en un coeficiente intelectual
si lo quieren ver de una forma muy
sencilla estamos hablando meramente la
inteligencia académica cuanto sacas te
sacaste 10 sacaste 8
pero por otro lado existe la
inteligencia emocional la inteligencia
emocional
se basa principalmente en la forma en la
cual los individuos somos capaces de
conocernos a nosotros y la forma de
trabajar con los demás
el doctor daniel goleman nos hace
referencia a que la inteligencia
emocional marca el 80% del éxito de las
personas el 80% entendiéndose que el 20%
restante
se lo podemos atribuir a la inteligencia
racional
momento eso no significa que la
inteligencia emocional sea más
importante que la inteligencia racional
o que la inteligencia racional sea más
importante que la inteligencia emocional
lo que tenemos que hacer es trabajar
para que ambas inteligencias
convergen
el logro de mezclar la inteligencia
racional con la emocional traerá consigo
tener
seres íntegros personas íntegras
personas racionales que piensan con el
corazón o que tienen la posibilidad de
trabajar en equipo
y no me hagan mucho caso pero esas
personas íntegras son las que necesita
este planeta
hay una frase
que marcó mi vida
pero si hay muchas frases que ha marcado
mi vida
recuerdo las de mi mamá y demás pero
creo que esas no tendrían que entrar en
esta plática
recuerdo cuando me encontraba en la
preparatoria y tuve la oportunidad de
leer esta frase
conocerse a sí mismo es el principio de
toda sabiduría claro no le dije yo la
dijo aristóteles verdad
y la importancia de esta frase viene en
el sentido de que si realmente no te
conoces
definitivamente no sabes qué quieres
hacer
oa dónde quiere llegar
precisamente por eso
quisiera poner en contexto la
importancia de conocernos a nosotros
mismos les voy a poner dos ejemplos
en el primero de ellos
a lo largo o es bastante común que a lo
largo de nuestra formación académica
siempre hayamos tenido compañeros que
hayan tenido mucho éxito en el colegio
que hayan sacado 10 que hayan tenido el
mejor promedio
[Música]
pero
cuando hacemos un análisis o al día de
hoy las redes sociales nos permiten como
tal conocer qué es lo que realmente está
pasando con nuestros compañeros
nos damos cuenta que esas personas que
académicamente eran excelentes
no necesariamente se encuentran del día
de hoy liderando
las empresas más importantes de méxico
cierto
pero por otro lado nos damos cuenta que
aquellas personas que en su caso no
tenían las notas más sobresalientes pero
tenían en su caso una facilidad para
poder trabajar en equipo
tenían una inteligencia emocional que
les permitía liderar grupos
son aquellas personas que al día de hoy
en el común denominador de los casos
tienen un mayor éxito que aquellas
personas que académicamente eran
sobresalientes
cuál es la razón de esto la razón de
esto se debe a la falta de inteligencia
emocional y al como aquellas personas
que sí la tienen o la han trabajado
pueden en su caso interactuar con otros
grupos
les daré a un segundo ejemplo
pongámonos en el contexto de que existen
como tal dos compañías con
circunstancias bastante similares
sin embargo las personas que en su caso
se encuentran dirigiendo estas compañías
se tienen que afrontar a tomar algunas
decisiones importantes
estas decisiones marcarán la existencia
o no de la compañía
representando que algunas compañías
dejen
o pierdan o tengan que correr a ciertos
trabajadores difícil
sin embargo algunos de estas dos
personas tomara una decisión adecuada
probablemente la hace la segunda tengo
un poco de miedo no sepa qué hacer no
sepa realmente
cuál será el destino de la compañía y la
llevará al fracaso
mismas empresas o empresas con
circunstancias similares pero al final
nos damos cuenta que las personas que
están liderando estas compañías no
tienen la suficiente potencia mental
para tomar esas decisiones
esto trae consigo es sinónimo en su caso
de que muchas empresas de reclutamiento
hagan mucho hincapié en que en la
mayoría de las ocasiones se contratan a
los altos profesionistas por su perfil
académico y su experiencia comercial sin
embargo estos son despedidos por la
falta de inteligencia emocional
y una vez que los he puesto un poco en
contexto de lo que es la inteligencia
emocional y como la inteligencia
emocional nos aporta en el éxito a nivel
profesional al menos
quisiera dejarles muy en claro la
siguiente fórmula
la siguiente fórmula me dice
el conocimiento más las habilidades
suman
pero la actitud
multiplica qué significa eso
es bastante importante que nosotros
tengamos una inteligencia racional claro
que es importante al final tenemos que
tener un background para poder tomar
algunas decisiones pero finalmente la
actitud es lo que marca la pauta es lo
que marca el éxito de las personas
en razón de ello yo realmente los invito
a que ustedes empiecen a reflexionar
primero conozcan sea a sí mismos
qué actitudes tengo qué aptitudes tengo
qué tanta inteligencia emocional tengo
realmente tengo que conocerme a mí para
saber a dónde quiero llegar o cómo
quiero llegar
[Música]
nuevamente les recuerdo
la suma de la inteligencia emocional más
la inteligencia racional trae consigo
personas íntegras personas completas
personas capaces de utilizar esa
inteligencia racional y de trabajar en
equipo
busquemos siempre
ser
inteligentes emocionalmente hablando
muchas gracias
[Música]